this episode is brought to you by Ridge
wallet hey wisecrack michael here still
in the same room in the same house I
haven't really left since March and I'm
recording another video all alone in
this room in front of the same god damn
boot
sorry about that folks
now I'm very eager to grab a drink with
friends without the specter of death
haunting me and I'm sure you are too a
citizens crave basic social interaction
and the economy craves our spending
technologies and policies designed to
prevent the spread of coronavirus are
popping up everywhere from boring but
well-established proven methods like
hand-washing social distancing and
wearing a mask over your mouth and nose
to newer approaches like smartphone
based GPS tracing and thermal imaging
cameras repurposed to check for fevers
governments and businesses are ready to
try anything that will get our terrified
asses off the couch and into the nations
cubicles and inexplicably sticky diner
booths now while we are 100% ready to
luxuriate in the Taco Bell dining
experience
we wouldn't be wisecrack if we didn't
ask the tough questions like to what
extent are newer policies surrounding
Cova 19 keep us safe from infection and
still harder to think about are they
even supposed to welcome to this
wisecrack edition on security theater
but before we continue I want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor Ridge
wallet the ridge wallet is a light sleek
and industrial wallet designed to last
you a lifetime each wallet is made with
RFID blocking technology which protects
you from digital pickpockets the durable
metal also means each wallet comes with
a lifetime warranty so this could be the
last wallet you've ever buy it's perfect
if you don't want to carry around a
bulky old leather lump in your pocket
but still want to maximize the amount of
cards you carry it old up to 12 cards
and still has room for cash the rich
team is so confident that you will like
it that if you don't and send it back
within 45 days you will receive a full
refund grab your own droid wallet today
by going to Ridge comm slash wisecrack
and use promo code wisecrack to get 10%
off you will get free worldwide shipping
and returns so click the link in the
description to get one today
now back to the show to be clear we're
not here to peddle conspiracy news masks
and social distancing work to
dramatically reduce the spread of Kovic
cover your nose kids but as we're about
to find out whether you're trying to
manage viruses or terrorism there's more
to this seemingly basic concept of
security than you might expect if you're
in a state that has tried reopening
restaurants and bars or even if you've
hopped on a plane you might have
encountered new procedures meant to make
us feel safe
these range from restaurants and bars
operating at diminished capacity to
states like New York only allowing
outdoor dining to businesses touting
extra cleaning procedures to buildings
and some airports testing out using
thermal scanners to identify people
running potentially kovat induced fevers
but not all strategies are equal some
are questionably effective at best and
potentially harmful at worst as Evan
Sellinger and Brenda Lee young put it in
a recent article installing thermal
scanning as part of a back to work
process might create a false sense of
security that convinces some to
prematurely return to their jobs and
emboldened others to relax more
effective strategies such as social
distancing and responsible contact
tracing efforts a quick definition
contact tracing is the practice of
tracking down people who were exposed to
another sick person in order to
proactively treat or isolate them and
contain the spread of the disease
selling her in Lyon claimed that thermal
scanning and other fancy looking quick
fixes are not true security rather there
were privacy expert Bruce Schneier has
famously called security theater or
security measures that make people feel
more secure without doing anything to
actually improve their security think
for instance of the little yard signs
that security companies plant in front
lawns to let passers-by know that the
designated house is protected by an
alarm now seeing that placard as you
come home every day may help you sleep
better at night which is arguably a good
thing in and of itself but it's
important to remember that the sign
itself cannot actually detect or prevent
a break-in or slow it down once it is
started when an angry Balrog comes to
steal your PlayStation that little piece
of metal on a stick is not going to pull
a Gandalf so you and your uninsured
gadgets can escape out the back door
maybe the sign deters people or maybe it
just advertises to thieves that they
need to be extra careful when robbing
as convenient as technologies like
remote temperature taking in real-time
phone enabled contact tracing would be
Salinger and Liam point out that so far
they just don't cut the proverbial
mustard Silicon Valley loves to tote
glitzy new GPS backed ways to track the
spread of disease but as reported in
Wired
many health officials don't consider
contact tracing programs that use
smartphone location data to be as
effective as traditional human based
contact tracing programs then there's
temperature checks and thermal imaging
airlines pushed and made for temperature
checks at airports dr. Martin citron the
CDC's director of global mitigation and
quarantine called the idea a poorly
designed control and detection strategy
and an earlier screening by the CDC of
over 30,000 passengers did not catch a
single kovat 19 case even though some of
the same passengers later tested
positive for the virus and per the
washington post thermal imaging cameras
have not demonstrated the ability to
detect internal body temperature with
the accuracy of more basic thermometers
in other words organizations around the
country are spending a lot of money to
install technologies that apparently do
not work for their stated purposes of
protecting people from infection but why
while in casual conversation we might
understand the word security to mean the
process of keeping people safe
Shanaya contends in his book beyond fear
thinking sensibly about security in an
uncertain world that it's not nearly
that straightforward according to him
what we call security is actually a
complex interplay between the differing
agendas of the various individuals and
organizations invested in a given
situation what he calls the players a
given security policy emerges out of the
negotiations between these players
influenced by the relative levels of
power between them resulting in a
program that serves the interest of the
most powerful players first and foremost
and may or may not actually increase
safety for end-users as an almost
secondary goal as an example Shire cites
the fact that in the immediate aftermath
of 9/11 tweezers and nail files were
banned on planes while some actually
combustible materials like lighters were
allowed through this
according to Shire was the result of the
relative influence of tobacco lobby on
the government's decision-making process
one player pressuring another big
tweezer unfortunately didn't have the
clout to stay off the TSH list security
theater happens when the more powerful
players involved are focused on our own
self-interest
to the detriment of the holistic
security of the system they participated
from these circumstances policies can
emerge that create the appearance of
doing something without actually making
people safer still players can find such
systems very attractive
Shanaya claims offering security theater
can improve market share just as much as
offering actual security and it is
significantly cheaper to provide he also
notes that most people are comforted by
action whether good or bad the most
infamous example of such a system is
again the post 9/11 Airport security
system and the wake of the attacks the
most powerful players involved had an
overriding political and economic agenda
to get people flying again as soon as
possible which meant that they had to
make the average citizen feel safe
enough to do so the resulting airport
security theaters satisfied the
government's need to implement a public
facing response to terror as well as the
airlines need for your sweaty pocket
cash in other words set system provides
the biggest players with what they want
while not necessarily making flying
significantly safer to put it bluntly
from this point of view the federal
government employs many thousands of TSA
agents and purchases an equal number of
hideous blue shirt and black pants
combos to make the average citizen feel
safe enough to fly even though the
process of taking off your shoes downing
your entire water bottle and one
ill-considered swig and having a tired
middle-aged man examine your junk via a
body scanner probably doesn't make you
that much safer consider for instance
the fact that in one nationwide test of
the system conducted by homeland
security in 2015 undercover agents were
able to smuggle mock explosives and
weapons through security checkpoints a
whopping 95 percent of the time you
thought your last annual review in bed
unfortunately many of the criticisms
applied to our handling of airport
security can be applied to some though
not all of our society's current
attempts to address the problem of
Corona
building off of shires Framework law
professor and privacy expert Peter Swire
has gone so far as to claim that we may
be facing a kind of public health
theater on par with the security theater
installed in the wake of 9/11 citing the
temptation for government agencies to
resort to unreliable phone
location-tracking as the lazy man's
approach to contact tracing
Swire claims that government officials
have great incentives to show the public
they are doing something anything to
address the crisis however Swire goes on
to note that absent an empirical showing
of accuracy and actionability that does
not exist to date calls for such
location tracking quite possibly our
security feeder rather than actual
security this description ties in neatly
with Snyder's framework and our current
moment the players involved in
formulating our collective policy for
handling coronavirus include governments
at the national state and local levels
and businesses ranging in size from
giant corporations to your local pizza
joint these players who have varying
levels of power bring to the table of
many different agendas in the case of
governments to be seen taking action
effective or not and to safeguard a
struggling economy and in the case of
businesses to attract enough customers
to turn a profit or at least keep
operations going perhaps there is no
better example of health security
theater than the quickly maligned
reopening plans of AMC theaters for July
as the LA Times noted the challenge is
not just reopening it's getting people
comfortable enough to show up so the
company sought to assuage fears by
reducing capacity and spending millions
of dollars on sanitation equipment while
all of those things can reduce the
spread of the virus the policy that is
most effective at keeping people safe
wasn't on the docket wearing masks while
the company would require employees to
wear them they would not universally
require patrons to that was deemed
political which is a nice way of saying
not good for business although the
company reversed course after backlash
and stated they would require masks if I
can make a somewhat unscientific analogy
the sanitation equipment is like that
dude at the frat party who wanted to
ride a razor scooter off of a roof
telling you chill bro I'll wear a helmet
and here our imaginary bro reveals a
basic danger of security theater
half-measures that make you feel safer
about doing
something incredibly dumb importantly
we're not here to malign safety measures
like wearing helmets are doing
temperature checks these things are fine
so long as they don't give people a
false sense of security as they Kareem
headfirst into a traumatic brain injury
or so long as they don't pull money and
other resources for more impactful
safety measures after all you don't want
to spend all your money on seatbelts for
a car known to burst into flames
now MCS craft mask policy is not unique
as restaurants and bars tout menu
cleaning and waiters clad and PPE many
are not requiring patrons to wear masks
as they amble past other diners to be
fair some businesses are just trying to
do the right thing keeping their
employees and customers safe while
trying to limit layoffs but as schneier
observed in the wake of 9/11
self-interest is a powerful force even
in the midst of a national emergency if
the best science says that the best way
to stay safe is to stay home and to
avoid the Cheesecake Factory quite
literally like the plague
it is in the restaurant players best
interest to ignore that data as much as
possible instead they might implement
relatively less costly security theater
measures that give people enough
confidence to drown their sorrows and
avocado egg rolls jokes aside their
recent tragic spikes and infection rates
in Arizona Texas Florida and California
demonstrate how security theater can
create a gap between the perception of
safety and an unsafe reality at its best
security theater can be a useful part of
a functioning society deterring lesser
threats while providing us some
day-to-day peace of mind at its worst
though as a byproduct of big players
desire for a swift return to normalcy it
can encourage average people to lower
their defenses before it's really safe
to do so with devastating consequences
but what do you think wisecrack are some
of the safety measures that we see just
for show or is everyone just scrambling
to do the right thing let us know in the
comments and be sure to subscribe and
ring that bell big things to our patrons
for supporting our podcast and the
channel and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]